في المرحلة الثالثة من تجربة اللقاح السريرية في الولايات
المتحدة ، بدأ
التحقيق في هذا اللقاح كما هو
معروف شارك في تطويره
شركة التكنولوجيا الحيوية Moderna
والمعهد الوطني للحساسية
والأمراض المعدية
ومن المتوقع أن يشارك ثلاثون ألف بالغ في هذه
المرحلة النهائية  تحدث أول متطوع
تلقى التطعيم
مع إليزابيث كوهين من CNN
حول التجربة
الآن فأنت لا تعرف ما إذا كنت قد حصلت على
اللقاح أو الدواء الوهمي ، ولكن في كلتا الحالتين ،
فإنك تساعد في العثور على علاج في كلتا الحالتين ،
إنه دور مهم حقًا أن تقوم به
و  لكي أكون جزءًا من هذا البحث
ولم أفكر مطلقًا في أنني سأفعل شيئًا
كهذا ،
كنت أول شخص في الولايات
المتحدة يحصل على فرصة في المرحلة الثالثة من التجربة المرغوبة ،
ما الذي يبدو أنه مثير للغاية
أم
أنا قلق جدًا حيال ذلك ، وآمل فقط
أن يكونوا جيدين حقًا في تحقيق
نتائج
جيدة ، لكنني أعلم أن الكثير من الأشخاص يجرون
الكثير من
تجارب اللقاحات المختلفة والأشياء جارية ،
ولكن
لدي رقم واحد  أشعر بالفخر
الشديد لزميل إليزابيث ، مراسل الصحة ،
جاكلين هوارد ، الذي انضم إلي الآن
من أتلانتا مع المزيد عن جاكلين في
المرحلة الثالثة
لمودينا ، ما الذي يمكن أن يتوقعه المتطوعون في
هذه التجربة
ومدى حجم الدور الذي تلعبه الثقة ،
هل تعتقد أن
الثقة تلعب دورًا كبيرًا ولكن  هذا ما
يمكن أن يتوقعه المتطوعون ،
كما قلت ، من المتوقع أن نرى
ما يصل إلى
30000 متطوع في هذه المرحلة التجريبية الثالثة
، سيحصل نصف المتطوعين
على دواء وهمي وسيحصل الباقون في
الواقع على لقاح كوفيد 19
واللقاح هو
سيتم إعطاؤهم على جرعتين ، جرعة 100
ميكروغرام الآن وبعد
28 يومًا بعد ذلك سيتلقون الجرعة الثانية
وهذه هي الطريقة التي سيقيس بها الباحثون حقًا
كيفية عمل هذا اللقاح ، ما سنرى
في المتطوعين مدى أمانه وفاعليته  إنه
كذلك وينظر إلى هذه على أنها الخطوة الأخيرة
قبل
أن نتمكن من تحديد نعم ، هذا اللقاح
جاهز ليكون متاحًا أو لا ، لذلك هذا
مهم جدًا وهو يتحرك حقًا
سرعان
ما تلقيت للتو مكالمة هاتفية موجزة عن بُعد
مع المعاهد
الوطنية للصحة والدكتور أنتوني فوسي ،
مدير المعهد الوطني للحساسية
والأمراض المعدية
، قال إن هذا هو
أسرع ما تحركت الولايات المتحدة حقًا للوصول إليه
لقاح مرشح من يناير عندما
تم وضع تسلسل الفيروس التاجي لأول
مرة والآن بعد حوالي ستة أشهر ، نحن
بالفعل في المرحلة الثالثة من التجربة
تتحرك الأشياء بسرعة وهذا
حقًا رقم قياسي بالنسبة
لنا وهي لحظة تاريخية بالنسبة
لنا  نحن سوف